it's time
to count down the top 100 what-ifs we've
ever made but we
can't squeeze all that into one video
so instead we're going to do it in our
first
ever what if 100 book
[Music]
join us as we dive deeper into the 100
most popular what if scenarios we've
ever explored
want to know what a portal to a parallel
universe would look like
well turn to page 51. want to know what
would happen if we dumped our trash into
volcanoes
that's on page 195 we're taking
everything you love about what if and
giving you more of it
more original artwork that transports
you into impossible worlds
more fun facts to help you understand
the science behind those worlds
more expert information including a
forward
written by legendary physicist dr michio
kaku
and on top of that a bonus list of
the most ridiculous what-if questions
asked by our fans
[Music]
so what are you waiting for pre-order is
available now on our website
shop.whatifshow.com get a digital
or a physical copy for your loved ones
or for yourself
because after all having this book on
your coffee table
is guaranteed to make you look smarter
so want to know what the most popular
what if ever made was
well that's a story for the what if book
[Music]
you